[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter theory in
this video were going to be discussing
Voldemort's background or more
specifically the fact that Voldemort
was a half-blood the Death Eaters seemed
so proud of their pure of magical
bloodlines so isn't it ironic of their
leader the Dark Lord Himself was a
filthy half-blood Tom Riddle or
Voldemort would always refer negatively
to his parentage over the course of the
books and films and we find out fairly
quickly there Voldemort's father was
indeed a muggle however the books and
films also a little bit conflicted on
whether or not Voldemort followers the
Death Eaters were actually fully aware
of this heritage after all how can they
truly be hateful of half-bloods and
muggles if the very person they follow
is one in this video we'll be addressing
the question did have all des morts
followers know that he was a half-blood
when Tom Riddle was first sorted into
Slytherin he didn't know of his heritage
but the books reveal in Chapter 17 with
the half-blood Prince that he quickly
became obsessed with it because he had
grown up in an orphanage it was only
natural that he sought answers and would
begin to look for clues within the
school
it seems he searched in vain for some
trace of Tom Riddle's senior on the
shields in the trophy room on the lists
of prefix in the old school records even
in the books on Wizarding history
finally he was forced to accept that his
father had never set foot in Hogwarts it
was actually Voldemort uncle morph in
gaunt that eventually revealed his true
heritage to him in the same chapter of
the half-blood Prince there is the
following exchange between the two I
thought you was that muggle whispered
Morphin he looked mighty like that
muggle what muggle said briddle sharply
that muggle what my sister took a fancy
to that muggle what lives in the big
house over the way said morph in
and he spat unexpectedly upon the floor
between them he looked right like him
middle but he's older now any he's older
than you now I think on it from what we
can tell
Voldemort became truly aware of his
heritage sometime between the ages of
fifteen and seventeen now there are a
few parts of the books and films that
suggest that the Death Eaters probably
know as well however it is never stated
directly to delve into this further I'm
going to start with a segment from page
231 of the Chamber of Secrets where
Voldemort reveals at some of his
intimate friends at school knew of both
his old and new identity he pulled
Harry's wand from his pocket and began
to trace it through the air writing
three shimmering words Tom Marvolo
riddle
then he waived the one once and the
letters of his name rearranged
themselves I am Lord Voldemort you see
he whispered it was a name I was already
using at Hogwarts to my most intimate
friends only of course you think I was
going to use my filthy muggle father's
name forever so given that some of
Voldemort's closest friends were aware
of both names we can say with some
confidence that there were people who he
went to school with that knew of his
heritage however this doesn't
necessarily mean that they went on to
become Death Eaters further to this in
chapter 23 of the half-blood Prince it
is revealed that fellow students found
it amusing
the Folden waltz father was a muggle
despite the fact that he was a
descendant of Salazar Slytherin himself
so it was never secret among his peers
that he was a half but this leads us to
our next and more important question who
did he go to school with and did they go
on to become Death Eaters a line from
page 463 of the half-blood Prince gives
us a clue good gracious is it that time
already you'd better get going boys
or we'll all be in trouble Lestrange I
want your essay by tomorrow or it's a
detention same goes for you Avery the
above passage mentions the name
of both the strange and avery both of
whom we know go on to become Death
Eaters if they went to school at the
same time as Voldemort and we know that
they become Death Eaters later on it's
fair to assume that they would qualify
as the intimate friends that Voldemort
had previously mentioned this would also
make them very much aware of his
heritage by the strange I am of course
talking about Voldemort Speer who we
believed to be related to would offers
the strange and if he's related to
Rudolph as' it means that Rudolph has
probably knows which means that
Bellatrix probably knows expanding on
this in chapter 35 of the order of the
Phoenix Harry mentions Voldemort's real
name Tom Riddle to Bellatrix which seems
to enrage her you dare speak his name
you filthy half-blood she responded this
again supports the fact that Bellatrix
is likely aware of riddles real name and
background so we can say definitively
that Avery and the strange no of
Voldemort's background but what about
the rest of the Death Eaters would they
have told other people would those who
met Voldemort after his schoolboy days
have the same level of understanding for
his situation in the Goblet of Fire
Voldemort addresses all of the Death
Eaters in a long monologue in his
monologue he discusses his need to
acquire his father's bone to regenerate
and then a necessity to travel to little
Angleton where his grave was located the
books imply repeatedly that little
Angleton is a small muggle community
which is definitely not a place that a
pure blood family would live pure blood
witches and wizards were very proud of
their bloodlines and the abundance of
witches and wizards that interpret with
muggles men a pure bloodlines were far
and few between in little Hangul ttyn
Voldemort's father's gravestone clearly
reads riddle so if the Death Eaters
didn't already know that Voldemort was a
half-blood this would have been a dead
giveaway as they would have been easily
able to recognize the riddle was not the
name of a known pureblood family so
though he did not speak of it entirely
openly Voldemort never really seemed
like he was trying to hide his back
in fact he was proud of murdering his
muggle father and I'm sure he encouraged
their theatres to follow in his
footsteps and murder any local family
that they had as well and that concludes
the video I hope you guys enjoyed it and
if you have any questions please leave
them down in the comment section below
until next time you're a wizard Harry
[Music]